on this Thursday night from London
coronation anticipation the Canadians
pumped about participating in this
moment of History the whole experience
has been completely surreal can the
monarchy survive with Charles in Charge
he needs public support and will he
reset the relationship with indigenous
people I am very hopeful New Revelations
contradicting the Prime Minister about
China's alleged threats to MPS as Ottawa
summons China's Ambassador and back to
work a tentative deal for Canada's tax
workers
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight from London
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are overlooking Westminster Abbey
tonight where King Charles along with
the queen consort Camilla will be
crowned on Saturday he will be the 40th
reigning monarch to be crowned there
since 1066. it is a place steeped in
history but it's 2023 a coronation may
seem like a throwback to another era yet
this will be an historic moment and
around Buckingham Palace excitement is
building hardcore monarchists are
already scoping out spots
but he's the king of our country we've
got to support our country you know
we're not Great Britain for nothing
we're just really excited to be here
within the atmosphere and to see the
coronation to see the king being crowned
it's just a momentous occasion everyone
loves a great party that part that
circumstance I think it just it lifts
all of our spirits
The Prince and Princess of Wales
surprised commuters on London's
Elizabeth line today named after Prince
William's grandmother
yeah
they were on their way to a Soho Pub
where William pulled a pint of King
maker beer a show of support for
Britain's hospitality industry big Royal
events can draw hundreds of thousands of
people to Central London whether King
Charles can do that we'll find out on
Saturday there will be Canadians here
including some taking part in the
procession Crystal the mansing has been
talking to some of them Crystal Dawn a
number of the Canadian Forces members
all use the word surreal when describing
their involvement and that really is
something special when you consider that
these individuals have traveled the
world they've taken part in training
exercises and of course been on
deployments so to see their eyes light
up to see a smile come across their face
when they talk about their involvement
is really something special to witness
in a sea of uniforms strangers unite 45
are bonded first by the maple leaf
followed by the history-making role
they've been selected to perform coming
to Canada in the way I did as a refugee
I've always been thankful to be a
citizen and and I've always wanted to
give back and to serve so there's no
greater way to do that I think than
being here High Praise for a ceremonial
role coming from a man who's used to
combat missions despite different ranks
and age the shared excitement within the
Canadian contingent is palpable King
Charles III is the commander-in-chief of
the Canadian Armed Forces and so the
Royal links are well known but it goes
deeper than that it's personal something
I never would have expected with this
once in a lifetime experience my
grandmother was as a kid at the
coronation of Hurley Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II in 1953
so yeah I think it'll just be very
special for me Captain Broderick Smith
has a special position in the military
parade alongside the gold State coach
which will carry their majesties back to
the Palace the whole experience has been
completely surreal I think as a 10 or 12
year old like at 12 years old I joined
the Rockne Army Cadets so I think this
is something that I would have aspired
to do as a ceremonial activity like this
so it's just phenomenal
oh division
408 members make up the division
composed of Commonwealth Nations and
Canada sent the largest contingent I can
say that we all were chosen of our
individual chains of commands uh within
the Navy they have a process and I guess
I'm very humbled to be here it's uh such
it's been exhilarating and surreal to be
part of this momentous occasion
just as they did seven decades ago for
Queen Elizabeth's coronation
Commonwealth members are staged at pair
bright Air Base in 1953 the Duke of
Edinburgh came to inspect the troops
today those on Parade were presented
with ceremonial coins I'm just excited
to start I'm excited to do it I'm
excited to see what the the period is
going to look like I'm excited to see
where this is all going to go and I'm
just excited for the day
in addition to the service personnel
there will of course be a number of
Canadians attending the coronation
service inside Westminster Abby that
list is sitting at at least 17 right now
let's give you a look at a few of those
individuals
of course the Prime Minister will be in
attendance along with his wife the
governor general will also be there on
Saturday
Roseanne Archibald the Assembly of First
Nations Chief will be there as well as
the president of the Inuit teparate
camarite that was Natan Obed
Cassidy Karen will also be there as well
as Margaret McMillan she's a historian
and Astronaut Jeremy Hansen
and Donna we should also note that
Canada's High Commissioner here in the
United Kingdom Ralph Goodale he will of
course also be attending that service
and as will some young people young
leaders from Canada will be a lifetime
of memories for those people Crystal
thank you absolutely
and Charles isn't resting before the
coronation he spent a little time inside
the Abbey behind me and later meta
delegation of indigenous leaders from
around the world including those who
have traveled here from Canada there is
hope the coronation might improve Crown
indigenous relations as Melissa ridgeen
reports with those High Hopes come high
expectations
he's known as an environmentalist and as
I've tried to indicate for quite some
time the climate crisis really is a
genuine emergency and tackling it is
utterly essential on the record
believing that indigenous knowledge and
Land Management are integral to
combating climate change these are some
of the reasons many indigenous leaders
see the coronation of King Charles as a
fresh start in what's often been a rocky
relationship with the crown Charles has
said some interesting things while he
was Prince you know he he uh he he was
looking at the uh at us he was
sympathetic to to us with the
residential school issue and and the um
you know unmarked Graves and he's also
had of takes very strong uh opinions on
climate change you know which is uh
positive in our uh from our perspective
so we hope if we can continue with that
uh refreshing point of view from the
previous Monarch I think there's
potential there to have a better
relationship with uh King Charles III
but they want action to be Swift and to
follow the vatican's lead in denouncing
doctrines that made colonization okay
the doctrines of Discovery and
teranullius at this
moment this this coronation would is an
opportunity for King Charles to reset
this relationship with indigenous
peoples after many many years and and
Decades of of genocidal policies that
were imposed on indigenous peoples this
would allow not only the the resetting
of relationship with indigenous peoples
here in Canada but elsewhere too around
the world that are within the
Commonwealth the Assembly of Manitoba
Chiefs will have a delegation in London
to remind the new king of his treaty
obligations Grant Chief Kathy Merrick
hopes he will put pressure on Canada to
be a better manager of these treaties
with fewer fights over resources rights
and sovereignty and it's time that we be
able to speak about treaties and our
relationship with the with the crown and
to ensure that we we
we reconcile that relationship I am very
hopeful of that
that uh with uh with the new king that
he be able to uh
to direct Canada to ensure that uh we
are treated in a good way as First
Nation people Melissa Ridge in Global
News Winnipeg
a little later a conversation about the
relevance of the king I talked to Royal
commentator Dickie Arbiter about how
much public support he thinks the Royals
have these days but first in Canada the
federal government summoned China's
ambassador to Canada today informing him
Canada will not tolerate any foreign
interference in its Internal Affairs
earlier this week it was revealed
Canada's spy agency concluded that in
2021 a Chinese Diplomat in Toronto was
involved in an alleged plot to
intimidate conservative MP Michael Chong
after he voted to condemn beijing's
treatment of its uyghur minority in the
House of Commons today Chong said ceases
told the privy Council Office about the
suspected plot when it happened two
years ago and yet nothing was done David
Aiken has more remember for Wellington
who knew what when Mr Speaker I've just
been informed by the National Security
advisor that the thesis intelligence
assessment of July 20th 2021 was sent by
ceases to the relevant departments into
the National Security advisor in the PCO
Michael Chong's Revelation in the House
of Commons suggests that the prime
minister's top security official was
told two years ago that Chong had been
targeted by the Beijing regime and yet
the PM on Wednesday said ceasis back in
2021 did not flag such a plot the
government stuck to that explanation
Thursday I can also assure him that as
the Prime Minister said and I said
earlier this week that we found out on
Monday of this week but the opposition
says the government's story does not add
up a massive hole has been blown through
the prime minister's story about the
foreign interference campaign and
harassment of a members of a member of
parlance family with the thesis
allegations now on the public record
Canada is taking dip diplomatic action
naive said it directly to my Chinese
counterpart that we will not tolerate
any form of foreign interference not in
our democracy not in our Internal
Affairs full stop but Chong and other
conservatives are demanding more they
want the Chinese Diplomat in Canada
alleged to have been part of the 2021
plot to be immediately expelled because
if we do not take that course of action
minister
we are basically putting up a giant
billboard for all authoritarian states
around the world that says we are open
for foreign interference threat
activities on Canadian soil targeting
Canadian citizens Canada may yet expel
that Chinese Diplomat and possibly
others but for now the government says
it is considering next steps Donna okay
David Aiken and Ottawa thank you the
union representing Canada Revenue Agency
employees says it's reached a tentative
deal with the federal government a
separate agreement has already ended a
strike of more than 120 000 Federal
public sector workers Mackenzie gray
reports on what's in this deal and why
it might not be the end of the labor
dispute
feed that the picketing and partying of
the public Sector Strike has come to an
end it's a sign of relief for our
members that have been 15 days on a
picket line so happy that they can go
back in the office and to you know
resume their their work to serve
Canadians the union of Taxation
employees settling on a 12 wage crease
over four years well short of the ute's
original ask of 30 percent over three
years the 3500 CRA employees also unable
to have the right to work from home
enshrined in their Collective Agreement
but they did get some concessions on
remote work being on the case-by-case
basis instead of being you know
wall-to-wall like a one-size-fits all
it's a huge difference they also got a
one-time 2500 bonus which helps cover
the wages lost during the strike
one-time bonuses are used to
grease the wheels for ratification but
that ratification seems to be far from
certain for CRA workers or the 120 000
treasury board employees who agreed to a
nearly identical deal on Monday we
thought there was a strong possibility
that we would be out for longer and so
we prepared for that the union
representing Service Canada and
immigration employees are urging their
35 000 members to reject the tentative
agreement with the feds we heard from
hundreds if not thousands of our members
who were upset feeling that the
agreement didn't go far enough and
didn't do enough for the lowest paid
employees in the federal public sector
to ratify the agreement a majority of
their members need to vote in favor of
the tentative deal a vote that's
expected to conclude in late June Donna
all right Mackenzie gray thank you the
mission to bring Russia's president to
Justice coming up a global news
exclusive with the chief prosecutor of
the international criminal courts
you're looking at Big Ben all lit up in
a colorful tribute to the king we're
back from London in a moment
[Music]
welcome back to London the Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski has made a
surprise visit to the international
criminal court in the Netherlands he
wants the Russian President Vladimir
Putin held accountable under
international law for the invasion of
Ukraine the international Criminal
Court's Chief prosecutor Kareem Khan has
issued an arrest warrant for Putin Khan
is in Ottawa today and he granted Global
News exclusive access to his first
official visit to Canada Korea isri
reports
three-day decision makers arrive on
Parliament Hill but few have as much
power and influence as this man Kareem
Khan is the chief prosecutor of the
international criminal court and he's
going after Russian President Vladimir
Putin we followed the evidence Ukraine
is a crime scene Khan issued an arrest
warrant for Putin last March
Russian forces are suspect many War
on the youngest victims the ICC has
accused Putin of a legally deporting
Ukrainian children to Russia we've seen
conflicts around the world very often
children are invisible I said before
Ukraine this would be one of the
priorities of my term despite the fact
Putin is a wanted man there is
skepticism including among some
parliamentarians about whether he will
ever stand trial at the Hague in August
Putin is expected to visit South Africa
an ICC signatory but the South African
government has already expressed
reluctance to arrest him can you give us
a sense Mr Khan of
um what options are available to the ICC
I have confidence that they will do the
right thing
responsibilities are mounting in the
current climate the court has long faced
criticism for its slow pace in
responding Khan says without enough
resources the ICC faces an uphill battle
but he believes he has a committed
partner in Canada this is a critical
moment I think in international Affairs
that either we hold on to the law either
we make sure the law is more relevant to
people that have no hope no protection
or we run the risk of having no law at
all
a pledge to uphold the rule of law at a
time when millions of people are
desperate for justice
teria is rate Global News Ottawa
[Music]
I had the people in a Northern Alberta
Community forced to flee a wildfire
you are looking at Parliament Square in
London we're back in a moment
[Music]
to Alberta now where a wildfire has
forced thousands of people to flee their
homes it's burning in the provinces
North near the community of Fox Lake and
is moving closer to the Little Red River
Cree Nation people there can only get
out by barge the Flames are already 200
meters away from the nearest homes on
3700 people living in the area are now
under a mandatory evacuation order and
it's being fueled by hot dry and windy
weather
some BC residents are facing threats
from flooding in communities in that
province's interior
the creek in Cache Creek is now a raging
River it's spilling into streets and
into buildings a state of emergency
remains in effect people in more than a
dozen homes are under evacuation orders
one house has already been destroyed
rapid snow melt and heavy rain are
fueling similar conditions throughout
Central and Southern BC triggering flood
watches and evacuations in a number of
regions
and in southern Quebec cleanup is now
underway after days of downpours and
devastating spring flooding River levels
are stabilizing now after more than 100
millimeters of rain fell since Saturday
more than 500 people have been forced
from their homes nearly 1 000 homes are
flooded and 3 000 are still cut off
police have recovered two bodies they're
believed to be those missing volunteer
firefighters who were swept away on
Monday
coronation conversation next I asked
Royal commentator Dickie Arbiter about
the challenges facing King Charles
you're looking at Westminster Abbey we
are back from London in a moment
[Music]
welcome back to London there is a long
Arc of History to the British royal
family it's been 70 years since the last
coronation took place here at
Westminster Abbey the royal family is in
it for the long game realizing that
without support from the public they
would not survive earlier today I spoke
to Dickie Arbiter about this he's a
royal Watcher and a former press
secretary to Queen Elizabeth
King Charles has spent his whole life
waiting to take on this 47 years since
he came out the Navy in 1976 no defined
role as the Prince of Wales he created
it created it first of all with the
prince's trust then started getting all
his hobby horse talking about the
environment people thought he was crazy
but here we are in the 21st century and
everything that Charles had said from
the time he took an interest in the
environment in the 1980s as come to a
fruition but he's been waiting to get
the big job he's 74. I mean in for most
people that's an odd situation it is an
old situation but there's no age limit
on the job as we saw with the late Queen
at 96. you know I've read I think it was
an Australian who said there was a time
when Prince Charles was about as popular
as a pork chop at a vegan Buffet
as popular as a pork chop at a vegan
Buffet right that's a good line it's a
pretty good line is
it do you think people's perception of
him has changed over the years oh
people's perception of him has changed
his popularity has grown everywhere he's
gone since he exceeded to the throne on
September the 8th last year
people who turned out in their thousands
and he's been very good he's a people
person he likes music people he likes
shake your hands with people he likes
talking to people look when he got back
to Buckingham Palace after late queen
died first thing he did car stopped
short of the gate he went up did a
walkabout he was pulled forward by a
well-washer give it a kiss on the cheek
and he needs public support he needs
public support the monarchy needs public
support monarchy only survives with
public support as long as the public
want the monarchy then it will survive
there's no there's no feeling here for a
republic there would be people who take
issue with that and and do want a
republic do do want the monarchy to end
it's not that big you think so it's
about that so so would you what do you
think the turnout will be for the
coronation look the turnout is going to
be big whatever way you look at it do
you think he is aware of the challenge
he faces in terms of winning people over
he is aware look his mother's a hard act
to follow he is not his mother Charles
is a different animal altogether he
likes a bit of fun look when he and
Camilla are out on the road they see
something funny
they giggle I don't care who sees it
they giggle they think if it's funny
it's funny and they laugh and that's the
sort of person he is do you think he'll
be nervous
I don't think he'll be nervous um he'll
probably be worried about a sort of um
uh the crowd on his head did they they
were do they rehearse that do you think
he's been rehearsed at the palace sort
of walking around the sort of marked out
ballroom with the crown on his head with
the crown on his head he weighs two
kilos yeah if you've got to practice
right you've got to practice yeah and
he's been practicing and she's been
practicing too yeah yeah so and then
they were there over at Westminster
Abbey yesterday yeah so yeah they've
been practicing is he nervous look he's
done these ceremonies so many times
it's it's ingrained in him and it'll go
okay he'll be all right she'll be all
right too they've got each other they'll
be great
and we will have live coverage of the
king's coronation and Camilla's on
Saturday it all starts at 5 a.m Eastern
2 A.M Pacific and I'll be right here
overlooking Westminster Abbey you can
watch it on global and on all of our
streaming platforms that is global
national for this for Thursday from
London I'm Donna Friesen thank you for
watching and hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
thank you
[Music]
foreign